I don't believe there is Sarah and you
know every time I hear set bladders
speak i'm reminded of the maxim better
to be quiet and be thought a fool than
the opens one mouth and remove all doubt
Sepp Blatter is practicing foolishness
of the highest order if he believes that
he will have another opportunity to lead
men and women around the world in the
world's most prolific sport what's
important to remember about Sepp Blatter
is that at no point today or ever has
this man who is in the penultimate
leadership position in world football
taking responsibility for the outcomes
of leadership in the game Paul Kelso is
right we've seen a football teams worth
of guilty admissions and indictments
around the corruption and bastardization
of this world's game and here near the
end no one including the man at the top
can take responsibility for what they've
done and attitude and organization
reflects leadership and we've seen that
again today yeah I mean he repeated in
that interview didn't he I can't be
personally and morally responsible for
these people do you think he genuinely
believes that he has done nothing wrong
I think people in power like Sepp
Blatter tend to convince themselves of
certain narratives and surround
themselves with sycophants and entourage
is that pump them full of a
self-fulfilling narrative but we're not
asking stepladder to be personally or
morally responsible for FIFA we're
asking Sepp Blatter and everyone in
football leadership to be professionally
and ethically responsible for the things
that they do and the position is that
they hold we're looking to flood the
institution with professionalism and
with ethical structure and in that
environment folks like bladder won't be
successful yeah I mean how do you make
fifa how do you turn FIFA around with
the end of the black
the error can it reform itself it hasn't
been able to thus far has it no I don't
think it'll ever reform itself from the
inside the last thing stakeholders like
all of us in the world's game can afford
is to allow another 20 years another
generation of the new guy same as the
old guy what we need to make sure
happens is that as many third parties
who are involved in transparency
involved in good governance involved in
democratic systems get involved and help
create a framework which by its very
nature illuminates the organization to
outside outsiders from the inside the
light no sunlight disperses cockroaches
and you know these cockroaches have been
the Galacticos of corruption we don't
need any new ones and transparency
openness in real time really setting a
new 21st century standard for
transparency and sport organizations is
what's required to move forward with
fefe yeah I mean corruption becomes so
entwined with FIFA it's almost part of
the DNA isn't it how who is the right
person to turn that around or is it
possible for one person or does it take
many many I think it takes many many I
think looking for the right person you
know asking who is the right person I
think that's the wrong question I think
the right question is how do we create
an organization that in every in every
way fields beholdin to feels wary of
feels scared of those that really give
power to world football which is all of
us we need to create an organization
that where leaders aren't really worried
about power but worried about execution
and the cost of not executing well so
that means you know institutional things
like term limits institutional things
like real-time board minutes real-time
executive board witnessing and it
includes things like
like no more secret ballots and includes
things like making the bid for any
particular tournament the technical bid
and that there's no other considerations
beyond the technical bid there's a lot
of things we can do but you know
worrying about getting great people
involved I'm less worried about that
than I am worried about getting great
frameworks involved in which really good
people can come along and do the work
Pokal so I'll set data about his legacy
what do you think his legacy is what
state as he led were left world football
in well i think you know his legacy is
the logical continuation of the Zhao
have launched manipulation of various
nations in order to hold power and do
with power what have launched in bladder
would from the very first election in
1998 bladder received votes from nations
who weren't even represented by their
national football administration bladder
recede vote from Haiti for example which
was given to him not by a haiti delegate
who could not make the extraordinary
congress but who was given to him by a
Trinidadian delegate so from the very
beginning of blador's presidency we have
seen a manipulation of the rules we have
seen a marginalization of justice and as
a result of that we see the elevation of
corruption moneyed interests and a
commodification of a game that really is
our culture and we need to get back to
you know football as more daily ways of
life and less about the
commercialization commodification of the
sport for those just at the very top